okay hey guys how's it going
exei sparks Game of Thrones I've not
been watching Game of Thrones maybe
other people have so I was playing black
against Aaron Gretzky who's a former
teammate of mine he's currently
attending Webster University I graduated
a couple years ago but we were on the
team for maybe we overlapped for about a
year and he's a strong player I mean he
should get his i''m title soon I think
he just needs her reigning he I think he
has all three norms but he hasn't been
having the best tournament and going
into this game he had half out of five
and yeah that didn't really mean that
much like he's still a good player so he
played e4 I was mostly expecting me for
he's also capable of playing London as
well as b3 on move one so I was
preparing for everything but II four I I
thought was most likely c59 of three e6
and I was expecting him to actually get
to this position and then play some
sidelines so I was prepared for like G 3
and C 4 and d3 and b3 and he played b3
so this is one of the lines I I've
reviewed beforehand clearly a sideline
the point is to play Bishop b2 and like
depending what block does sometimes like
goes for d4 sometimes like goes for c4
it's an interesting line if anyone plays
this e six on move to as black and you
don't know to do against b3 I think the
simplest setup is to play b6 like all
soffietta the bishop and hip upon so
that's what I did you played Bishop d3
which was a little bit weird I mean I
would think most people start with
Bishop to b2
I don't think it mattered like too much
so Bishop d3 there should be seven
castling and now I think that next one
was very important and in preparation
for this game I looked at looked at some
game where black played black brought
this Knight to g6 where it was actually
a very nice square it because it had
access to f4 and e5 to have some some
pressure against submission also to
coordinate with this bishop like some
somewhere like far down the road there
there might be some some pressure
against g2 so I play 97 it's a bit
slower to develop the knight of 6 but I
thought it was was worth the extra tempo
so Bishop b2 my g6 c4 yeah c-4 I guess
idea of Knight c3 I was already feeling
pretty comfortable knight c6 rook e1
Bishop d6 and then Knight a 390 a 3 was
maybe a bit unexpected it's expecting
more like Bishop f1 and d4 93 I guess
one point is that I can't really play
Queen c7 right away and allow night to
be 5 however the night was a little bit
misplaced and I thought it was a good
opportunity to to strike um actually I
should note when I play Bishop d6 I do
leave this pawn on g7 I see Gabriel 8a
asking can't white take on g8 but he
means g7 yeah I'm pretty sure this is a
poisoned pawn because Bishop takes g7 I
have rooked g8 the bishop has to move
I'll say the bishop moves back and then
I have this move it's actually a nice
calculation I hit the bishop and the
pawn only moved to the fend off is
Bishop f1 and then the initiative
continues Knight h3 king h1 Knight takes
F 2 and I win the Queen
so that's the reason why white can't
take on on g7 it just walks straight
into this variation
oh yeah Bishop h6 is uh maybe a better
try that's actually true there's a page
six I still felt like I was having some
initiative
maybe this move like this looks really
fun for black I'm hitting the rook I'm
also aligning with this bishop if Knight
c3 and I just want to keep the
initiative here maybe this move I think
black has full compensation hitting the
bishop hitting this bishop actually both
bishops are hanging now and yeah black
should be winning a piece so that's why
sometimes pawns that look free are not
actually free so yeah sometimes like you
can leave stuff undefended but it's
actually defended by like tactics and
initiative so Knight a3 was played now I
play 95 and now I start getting
initiative I realize like all my minor
pieces have potential to attack and this
might was out of play and like Queen can
come in potentially so I played 95 to
try and remove this Knight to access g5
or h4 also Ptolemy CH the bishop so I
was feeling pretty good here Bishop f1
takes takes and then when I initially
took on f3 I was thinking I could play
f5 in this position and then I realized
it wasn't so simple I mean that first I
thought f5 was just crushing but there's
actually a really I think a really
strong move for White's
which kind of muddies the waters because
on the surface okay I'm just attacking
the pawn if t3i castle and whites under
major pressure but white has this move
Queen to d3 and it hits a bishop which
isn't defended and then the threat is
also to take the pawn I'm meeting the
rook
I was trying to calculate something here
like Queen c7 takes Knight f4 but it
just didn't seem right
imagine the Queen can just slide over
and wait a minute does this work
I have Knight h3o I don't have 93
okay so Queen c3 I was thinking here
takes and then this is mate because the
bishop action
unfortunately earth Queen takes h3 so
yeah so f5 I mean it's it's a very like
standard idea for this sort of setup but
it can't be played right away so I
played Queen g5 maybe there is some
alternatives but I thought Queen g5 is
it's a very intuitive move and then he
plays d4 now I'm starting to realize
maybe I should not have allowed like d4
but it's kind of hard to prevent
first I mean when I played Queen g5 I
thought d4 is just not possible because
I take and the Knights hit but then he
has Knight b5 and white got some
initiative so so I decided to castle and
he gets him d5 so trying to block this
bishop so I play rook to e8 I wanted to
put the rook here so that after Knight
b5 Bishop e8 my rook isn't stuck on AIDS
so I went for this I mean I was still
feeling comfortable ideas of f5 and this
night stole out of play I thought my
pieces were we're working in harmony he
played like b5 Bishop e8 then Queen c3y
after Queen c3 okay he's threatening
mates and I had a few candidate moves
here I could play Bishop e5
I could play like any knight move I
chose Queen h6 I thought this is this is
reasonable
he played g3
the natural move so his pawns were
actually working quite well to undermine
both my bishops so I wanted to open up
diagonals and I wanted to play a five
but we'll get to that point first I play
six kick from like back to three and
then Bishop to e5 I really wanted to
play f5 here but I didn't play a five
because he has this annoying move Bishop
to c1 queen h5 and then Bishop e2 and my
queen is actually very short on squares
if if the Queen moves to h3 Bishop f1
and I mean we could repeat but I thought
I was playing for a win
then what ended up happening like
somewhere within a few moves my position
just became much worse so maybe I should
have gone for this but then he told me
after the game if I play that five he
would take and then I would take here if
we got this position I think I would be
relatively happy and use of rook a fate
it's still kind of a complicated fight
anyway I played Bishop e5 and then I
play off five this way like if he plays
Bishop C one I have f4 to block the the
bishop so takes
oh yeah and after take I take on b2 so
now there's no more worries about Bishop
c1 and then I take on a5 he played
Bishop to g2 and then I play rook F
eights and I actually don't know where I
went wrong in this game but his next
move I feel like was maybe a turning
point it's a move that I I kind of
dismissed as being too weakening but it
turned out to be very strong pawn a for
completely like restricting like one
pawn move restricts like all my pieces
on the Kings side like my Queens out of
play my knight
restricted my rooks have no influence it
was actually really annoying
and he was able to play this move
because there there's some some like
favorable tactics surrounding the the d5
pawn favorable for whites it's the fact
that after I take I'm not actually
winning a pawn I don't think because he
has might see to and my pawns pinned and
he's threatening Knights III and then
this is where I realized the position is
just very difficult oh I wanted to play
something like Bishop AIDS so just to
demonstrate like one issue with rook h5
so after 93 rook h5 looks like I'm
threatening this my bishops defended so
I have these ideas maybe the chat can
find the move for a white in this
position
White's a move find the best move
completely winning on the spot
very simple Queen shot Knight g4 good
job diamond color my queen I thought my
Queen was good on each six earlier but
in this position it's just ridiculous so
after night c2 I play trick f7 because I
realized my knight is just garbage
I want to maneuver it to a happier place
and and also support d5 so ninety three
ninety seven and now rook to you one and
so you found like all these strong moves
like keeping the pressure on d5 and the
point for whites is that like if he
takes immediately what ends up happening
is there eventually becomes a pawn on d5
and I don't think White has any like
pole here but he plays rook t1 to have a
piece on d5 if he keeps a piece on d5
then the file remains half opened and
this pawns a weakness and he 6 d six
square is also a weakness I still can't
deal with the pin I think this pin was
so annoying
if I play Bishop c6 I mean that maybe he
can take the pawn and I lose to him
but he's already to already ready to
take with a piece another move I wanted
to play was d4 here to attack the knight
and maybe trade like Bishop for Knights
but this doesn't work because takes
takes needs Bishop g5 so another reason
I started with 97 so Rick do you one
have I reviewed with the computer yet no
but I'll check after the game yeah I
definitely want to see what the engine
or how the engine would improve and and
what the valuation was when I thought
the position was like it was pretty good
for me
so we'll go forward Queen g6 I was happy
with this move the idea was if he takes
a bunch of times on g5 it looks like he
wins a pawn back but then I went off for
because of the pin so yeah Queen g6
aligning with the king he plays Queen d2
this was good move putting more pressure
on the pawn now I play d4 yeah I was
just trying to like relieve the
attention he takes takes rook tix and
now I play Knight f5 but I think already
here like White has a pretty nice pole
because my I mean my King side pieces
are still restricted and White has all
this pressure on the D file and the
bishop bishop d5 is always looming and
he just moves back to you one very
patient move now if I had a couple moves
here if I got like two moves in a row to
play King h8 in 94 I think things would
be perfectly fine I was just a little
bit too slow so I start with King h8 and
he plays very strong move Bishop oh he
starts with Bishop d5 and then he plays
Bishop efore this is a strong idea
first removing my rook from defending
this pawn and then pinning my Knights
and now I I have to worry about the pawn
and also the pin I'm also back ranked
ideas like there's certain lines
I mean Queen d3 is probably the simplest
good job to people who are suggesting
Queen d3 attacking the Queen and I have
no time to take as my queen with hang I
traded in hindsight maybe I should have
kept Queens on the board I thought maybe
the ending was whole double without
Queens but queen g4 is probably a better
option and from this point forward I
would just like to praise my opponents
and game technique like Aaron just I
think he just played flawlessly he gave
me no counter play like the thing about
this ending if you're playing black you
want to somehow activate your rooks and
and penetrate the position but like why
it was controlling both open files and I
didn't realize how much of a problem
that would be until it was pretty much
too late so I kind of just had to wait
around while white improves I was also
very low on time at this point yeah why
it was just so dominant I can never like
one active idea b5 can almost never be
played because he 5 hangs so yeah people
should just watch and learn like how to
convert an endgame like this because
white still needs to make a pass pawn
and sometimes white needs to like target
other weaknesses too so he eventually
did was made progress on the Kings side
and also keep an eye on these green side
pawns
I played g6 I didn't want to allow h5 I
thought that would be not so pleasant
but he still played h5 hey victorious
Fuchs thanks for something so h5 takes
takes so in this position I thought I
was getting counter playing in spawns I
play rook g7 threatening this King f3
and then I play rook g6 so I thought I
was making like some improvements but
then he played the move I completely
forgot about I was expecting rook h3
here so this is another question for the
chat what did white play in this
position which is probably just the best
move and it's not rookie h3 and I have a
very clear threat so white to move yeah
rook g5 rook dg5 of course to keep this
pin this is a nice move it actually
sacrifices a pawn but if I take twice
like takes takes takes takes takes it's
a losing King pawn ending just here and
yeah actually waits here g4 here here
whoa it's a sound whoa Herald or Khaled
AJ donating $10 just started playing
chess and learning from you good to hear
thanks so much appreciate that yeah this
is a pretty like simple endgame I think
I was trying to calculate this so like
King here
a5 a4 yeah I have to move back and
White's gonna be faster to promote so
yeah egg games like this you want to at
least keep rooks on the board
I played a5 I played a5 with like 5
seconds left
there was a 30 second increments but I
was just so low in time I was trying to
find like some sort of counter play he
played a 4 player up to 6 I was dreaming
of getting 6 moves in a row but it
seemed quite work rook d5 was good move
yeah I mean he just killed all my
counter play like this rook
like by the time this rook got active I
was just losing all my pawns King f6 he
actually repeated but I mean there is
still no hope he has very simple idea
locking his king up and my king ever he
moves to g7 he'll check me if my rook
every moves to the seventh rank he'll
check me here and win this pawn so life
was sad I play rook e6 still dreaming of
winning this pawn plays king h4 I play
rook to e4 if I play rook e3 and he can
check and win this I was thinking about
playing rookie three hoping for king h5
and then I win because of mates but
obviously okay at this level I mean it's
just just completely winning for White's
love-hate chess slumming for five months
on a streak thanks love hey chess so I
play rookie for Chuck I I gave him a
choice which pawn to take so I at least
at least I won one of his past plans
King of seven but now he's winning these
pawns so things kind of simplified and
I'm just down three pawns this is a dead
loss I was hoping to like win one of
these pawns and maybe trying like
complicate things
the problem is he keeps everything
defended here and like every single
pawns defended afar saying thanks for
subbing so the rest of the game I'll
zoom through there was one last trick
which maybe some people will appreciate
I played rook c3 actually when I played
rook c3 I was imagining a final trick
and even if he like falls into the trick
I'm I'm pretty sure it's still losing
for me but the trick was I was trying to
entice him to play a six let's imagine
he plays a six then I would move back
now it looks like he can check force my
king somewhere here check and then push
the pawn just seems like good hanging
technique so let's say Chuck here Chuck
here push this would be falling into the
trick because I can take and he can't
take back because of stalemate so I was
trying to set up like something kind of
like a last-ditch effort but like even
if we get to this position I mean this
is still waiting for whites do pawns is
enough but always keep an eye out for
first steel matrix actually in this
position I was trying to figure out like
with this formation how I can somehow
provoke his rook to the seventh rank but
okay he just starts with checking and
then pushes oh yeah I was still hoping
for rook c7 a seven but he just plays
King f5 and push this other pawn and
then I was playing it out cuz you never
know miracles have happened in the past
but he converted father's see I actually
here like this was just force win like
Jerry over here here if my King moves
here there's Queen d5 my King moves here
there's Queen me five so this is how the
game ended this is my first loss for the
tournament not the most desirable result
yeah if people want to press f to pay
respects feel free to do so